[inaudible].
He's a politician,
but he's not just any politician.
His biography is what you'd expect from
the protagonist of a best selling
political fiction novel.
However,
the viewer,
this is a flesh and blood politician
with both the good side and the dark
side.
We're talking about Benjamin Netanyahu,
Israel's prime minister,
and it's the most powerful politician in
the country has had in the last two
decades.
This is a country that works.
People work the invent things,
and when things that change live,
this is past is future.
Yes,
I found in the Times that I've been in
government that the most rapid
technology transfers occur when
businesses operate within Israel is
often called the startup nation.
I call it the innovation nation.
The future belongs to those who
innovate.
Those who don't innovate rather than
companies or in countries will fall
behind.
Innovation is the only way to
consistently add value to your products
and services in an increasingly
competitive global economy.
Bye.
You may be wondering,
why are we talking about Netanyahu
today?
Why is he so important?
Well,
folks,
what if I told you that this man was the
architect?
He basically designs the Israel that we
know today.
Yes,
you heard that,
right?
We're talking about a politician who has
so much character that he actually
attacked the very presidents of the
United States in front of his own
congress.
Yes,
indeed.
This happened to Barack Obama,
so don't tell me that this guy isn't
huff before lifting those restrictions,
the world should demand that you long to
do three things.
First,
stop.
It's aggression against its neighbors in
the Middle East.
Second,
stopped supporting terrorism around the
world,
and third,
stop threatening you are nine late my
country,
Israel.
The one and only
[inaudible]
fact is that Benjamin Netanyahu or bibby
as is known in Israel,
done practically everything in his
country during his time as a soldier.
And remember here,
the military service is mandatory in
Israel.
He commanded a special forces unit,
antibiotic [inaudible] and plenty of
operations which have names liquid you'd
see in a Hollywood movie,
names like operation in Ferno hands
operation,
a tape where by the way,
ness and Yahoo was shot while his unit
rescue to plane hijacked by the
terrorist group,
the Black September organization.
Look,
I'm 28 years old.
I've had to defend my country in two
wars and in many battles
as a soldier.
He also participated in operations in
Egypt,
Syria and Jordan.
That's not all.
After finishing his military service,
this prime minister went to the United
States to study as well.
Now you might be wondering,
well where did he study?
Well first it was mit and then it was
Harvard and by the way,
here's some curious trivia.
In 1973 when the Yom Kippur war broke
out between Israel and its Arab
neighbors,
Netanyahu who was studying in Boston
returned home to rejoin the special
forces until the war ended.
But moving on from Trivia,
that's continued.
The fact is that after studying in the
United States and spending some time
working in consulting,
he got involved in politics where again,
he's done everything.
He has been a member of parliaments and
Ambassador to the UN Minister of foreign
affairs,
Minister of finance,
and of course prime minister for four
towns.
In fact,
my friends,
he's about to become the Israeli prime
minister with the longest time in
office.
However,
now his position of influence and power
is being questions.
So let's take a look at what is
happening or why this man is an election
winning machine
cornered
on February the 12th 2018 after a year
of investigations,
the Israeli police recommended the
attorney general bring charges against
Benjamin Netanyahu.
You see the police state there are clear
indications of corruption,
bribes,
and influence peddling.
They accused the prime minister of
having received gifts of hundreds of
thousands of dollars of having good
spires do influence the media and also
of having protected millionaire
corruption in the multimillion dollar
process of buying German submarines.
And do you know what?
This isn't the first time that Israel
is,
police have accused him.
They also did it in 1997 and again in
1999 during that and Yahoo's first term
as prime minister back then the
accusations ended with no charges.
And now again,
the prime minister has made it very
clear that he will not yield nothing.
We'll have sway and nothing will sway
me.
Not even the incessant attacks against
me,
Benjamin Netanyahu.
The truth is that whether or not he's
finally accused.
Netanyahu is on the line.
By the way it Israel,
nobody is immune to justice.
In the last decades they have condemned
and the prison's a former prime
minister,
accurate almost has an ex presidents,
Moshe Katsav.
So if Fidessa Yard,
he was guilty and he's got a pain.
Therefore it,
if you were in this video,
we're going to get to know Israelis,
prime minister besser.
We're going to take a look.
It is good and his bad side and
investigates what made an and Yahoo is
such an important character in Israel's
politics.
He beebe the savior.
Listen,
you're,
we might not be the most popular guy on
the planets,
but one thing is absolutely certain.
Every time bibby has come to power,
he's done.
So I was a very,
very difficult conditions.
Sure.
During
his first term when he came to power
1996 the country was greatly unbalanced
with an uncontrolled public and deficits
and growing external debt.
In 2003 when he was appointed minister
of finance under aerial Sharon's
governments.
If the country was undergoing its worst
recession and the most current time was
in 2009 just when his country was
suffering the consequences of the
greater international financial crisis.
Well,
in all these cases,
Netanyahu's recipes they works.
And not only that,
with his policies,
pity has transformed this country's
identity.
Thanks largely to his governance.
Israel has gone from being a place with
chronic imbalances and crises.
A country,
there's,
in 1984 had to be rescued by the United
States to becoming a prosperous country
with well organized accounts and say
worldwide power in technology and
innovation.
Through all this,
we can understand how despite all the
controversy maybe continues to raise
passions,
some against him,
but many in favor of him,
but many of you might not be thinking,
okay,
but what,
where?
Or rather,
what are Benjamin Netanyahu's recipes?
While that's exactly what we're going to
look at next.
Traditionally Israel was a socialist
country with high taxes,
a lot of regulation,
and a very large governments.
Well,
they're these mission was to change this
model once and for all and in force
another that would organize the accounts
and improve the country's competitive
dust.
I mean,
check this out.
You think that
mathematicians and computer engineers or
mechanical engineers or doctors or first
they're very important,
but they're not first,
they're second.
There was a country that had the best
mathematicians,
the best physicists,
the best metallurgists in the world,
but that country was very poor.
It was called the Soviet Union.
What comes first is markets.
This was the main thing that I tried to
bring to the Israeli economy in my own
way.
Benjamin Netanyahu
with this idea in mind and its first
mandate in 1996 is number one priority
was to reduce the public deficits.
Privatized banks and large government
owned companies and suppress capital
controls.
For example,
at that time,
Israelis had a restriction on the money
that they could take out of the country
and to use for buying foreign currency.
Yes,
we could say that the Israel of the
nineties resembled the coaching is
Argentina,
a lot of public spending and capital
controls,
but let's continue.
In 2003 when the country was undergoing
a terrible crisis as minister of
finance,
Minister of Finance with a lot of power.
By the way,
Netanyahu froze public spending and
launched a huge tax reduction.
For example,
he reduced corporate income tax as well
as individual income tax by half.
See,
when he arrived at the ministry,
the maximum rate on income in terms of
wages was 64% when he left,
it was 44% a 20 point reduction in just
two years and when he came to power in
2009 he had a similar recipe that's
public spending,
fewer taxes and less.
In addition,
in recent years,
he managed to get Israel once and for
all to exploit its huge natural gas
reserves.
Israel bolsters Egypt ties with $15
billion gas deal.
It was precisely because of this that
many believe Israel is miracle would not
have been possible without this prime
minister,
but don't think that he has only had
good results in the economic sector,
not at all
in the 37 months that Netanyahu held
office Israeli citizens enjoyed or one
of the safest and quietest periods with
regards to terrorism.
Of the five is really leaders examined
Robin Perez,
Netanyahu,
Brock Sharone,
Netanyahu's policies with regards to the
prevention and deterrence of terrorism
where the most effective
indeed in addition to the economy,
Israeli society recognizes net and Yahoo
has having made Israel a safer country.
I save the country and also very
importantly the country that is much
more open to the world.
So much so that this prime minister has
succeeded.
And this is not here because I think
this will amaze you in getting relations
between Israel and the Arab countries to
go smoothly.
And this is something that we certainly
need to dive more into man.
What do that right now,
external approach.
So you probably know the popular saying
my enemy's enemy is my friend.
Well,
it looks as if something like this is
happening in the Middle East with Iran
and to with fundamentalist groups like
Isis.
I mean check all the news that the New
York Times published on February the
third 2018
secret alliance is real carries out air
strikes in Egypt with Kairos.
Okay.
Pay Close attention to this new spot.
In the last two years,
Israel has carried out more than a
hundred area.
The tax with planes,
helicopters and drones against
fundamentalist groups in Egypt's,
particularly against the so called
Islamic state of Sinai that is an Arab
governments.
In this case,
the Egyptian government has authorized
Israel to carry out attacks and
operations within its territory,
which is really quite amazing,
but that's not all.
Israel's relations with Jordan and Egypt
are better than ever,
but they're also growing stronger with
other Arab countries including Saudi
Arabia.
Yep.
You heard that rise.
Now they still aren't formal but they
are happening behind closed doors.
There is an alignment of Israel and
other countries in the Middle East that
would have been on imaginable 10 years
ago.
Certainly in my lifetime I never saw
anything like it.
And I met the age of the state of Israel
have more or less.
So it's an extraordinary thing.
So how about another example?
Well after 70 years of prohibition and
for the first time Saudi Arabia has
authorized in Israeli commercial flight
to cross it's ass space since March Air
India flights between New Delhi and Tel
Aviv.
Well cross Saudi ass space.
This might seem like a small step but
it's written not and you know what?
It's not just the Arab countries.
The prime minister has set his sights on
the and there's also establish
surprisingly good relations with India,
Australia,
Singapore and even China.
We are very much very much excited by
the belt and road initiative and what we
feel is merely an express lane.
This belt and road that is called the
China is going to relations
and once more that's in Yahoo led the
first visit of an Israeli prime minister
to Latin America in 2017 he visited
Mexico.
Columbia and sergeants has an Africa.
Wow.
Smart.
Israel is coming back to Africa and
Africa is coming back to Israel.
Okay.
In fact,
that's in Yahoo was the first Israeli
needed to visit this consonant since the
1960s and many African leaders aren't
delighted with Israel's money and
Israel's technology.
Jake,
diversity and richness.
I saw passion and productivity.
I saw a young African entrepreneurs who
are building companies,
harnessing the power of the digital age.
Africans are seizing the future.
Israel wants to seize this future with
you.
In short,
as you can see you both in the economic
field as well as insecurity and foreign
policy.
There's prime minister as many reasons
to be proud,
but of course not.
Everything is a bed of roses here.
Okay.
Dark side.
We just announced it before on visual
politic.
One of the greatest problems we see with
Benjamin Netanyahu in addition to his
corruption suspicions,
is his position towards the West Bank
settlements.
Yes.
And that's in Yahoo supports these
settlements,
continual growth.
And as we saw in recent years,
this government has promoted to policy
to expand and consolidate them,
and it's more than three years in power.
This government has been irrational,
bordering on the messianic does now
increasingly clear where it is headed.
Creeping annexation of the West Bank
aimed at precluding any permanent
separation from the Palestinians who
barack former prime minister of Israel.
And besides these settlements,
Netanyahu's power relations with some
magnates a raw,
so Ashley put it questionable.
For example,
his friends and gambling mogul Sheldon
Adelson invested $200 million into
Israel high on a free newspaper that
greatly favors net in the yard.
Hi,
a question that arises is what you have
to return the favor and other
significance.
Parts of Netanyahu's dark side has to do
with his way of doing politics is a
tough opponent who has no qualms about
attacking his rivals through all
possible means.
That is precisely what he did in 1995
with prime minister.
It's soccer robyn,
who he accused among many other things
of portraying Jewish values,
potentially need generated,
were so great that many detractors blame
him for the hatred that ended with
Robin's murder at the hands of an
extremist.
His critics say that Netanyahu didn't
pull the trigger,
but that is a lack of political piety
that to the tragedy.
So that Divya is the end of this video
about a politician who has a dark side,
but also a very bright one as well.
He has contributed to making Israel a
much more prosperous country,
but now it's your turn.
What do you think of Benjamin Netanyahu,
do you think can bibby has been a good
leader for Israel?
Well,
leave us your comments in the comment
section below as well as in this survey
and I really hope you enjoyed this
video.
If you did,
please do hit that like button and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday.
Also,
do not forget to check it.
Our friends at the reconsider media
podcast,
they provided the vocals in this
episode.
That one was mine.
And as always,
thank you for
watching.
This room is coming back to Africa and
Africa is coming back to Israel.